salut aujourd'hui je vous fais une de
mes énigmes préféré est juste avant je
vous donne la réponse de l'énigme d'hier
si vous n'avez pas vu l'énigme d'hier
regardez la vidéo d'hier avant d'écouter
la réponse je voulais dit lampadaires sa
touche fauteuil ça touche pas canapé ça
touche caméra ça touche ne touche touche
pas c'est le fait de parler de caen les
lèvres se touchent ou pas quand je dis
le mot touche mes lèvres elle ne se
touchent pas par contre quand je dis de
touche pas pas là l'élève se touchent
donc touche pas touche
alors que touche touche pas vous pouvez
vraiment vous marrez entre amis à faire
ce jeu devant quelqu'un d'autre sans
jamais lui donner la solution il doit
comprendre et de temps en temps vous
pouvez lire a bâti trois bouteilles
bouteille sa touche et c'est à lui
trouver la logique j'espère que j'espère
que vous allez rendre fou plein de gens
avec ça c'est vraiment très drôle à
faire et on passe tout de suite à
l'énigme du jour
cette énigme numéro 30 est une énigme un
petit peu de logique de mensonges et de
vérité comme on avait pu faire déjà
précédemment avec un homme fictif que
nous appellerons nous appellerons
raymond voillat raymond et sur une île
déserte et sur certaines idées à téhéran
compte de tribus donc déjà hésitant lé
pa tré est déserte mon île déserte
il ya la tribu des mental et la tribu
des blogs est ce que ces lignes du
pantalon blog et apprend que dans la
tribu des mental on dit toujours la
vérité toujours toujours alors que dans
la tribu des blogs on dit toujours l'
inverse on ment toujours toujours mais
bon comme on sait que c'est la tribu des
blogs on sait qu'il faut inverser les
réponses et en se baladant sur l'île il
rencontre trois personnes team menthe et
à l'eau donc ils rencontrent ces trois
personnes qui s'appelle team menthe et a
loupé
qu'est ce que ce bien trouver les
prénoms des on manque lui dit un seul de
nous trois et mentale à l'eau lui dit
nous sommes tous les trois de la tribu
vlog donc ma question et des trois
hommes
lesquels font partie de la tribu vlog
donc la tribu qui dit toujours l'
inverse de ce qu elle pense qui ment
toujours
et lesquels font partie des attributs
mentale et donc disent toujours la
vérité est logique a pas d'embrouillé ya
vraiment une logique qui va vous permet
de trouver la réponse dès que vous
l'avez trouvée ne mettez pas dans les
commentaires laissés les autres chercher
mais t'es juste j'ai trouvé surtout
mettez un pouce en l'air pour savoir qui
avait trouvé la réponse à l'énigme passé
un très bon samedi et surtout un très
bon samedi soir si vous faites la fête
ce soir n'oubliez pas de vous abonner
avant de partir puisque mentale blog
c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an
rendez vous donc demain à 11 heures je
lui ai déjà dit ciao